all right David
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally I was born and raised in New
Jersey
um
pretty much as far away from here as you
can get I was born in Princeton
I lived with my dad uh and my grandma
because my mom was an unfit mother until
I was five and then he committed suicide
and at that point I had to go live with
my mom because she was my only parent
left your mom was in why was your mom
unfit
I don't know
um I don't really know the whole story
I've heard bits and pieces
um I do know that she she wasn't really
that forthcoming about her age when she
was with my dad
um and he got the marriage annulled
because she was younger than she claimed
to be
um
yeah and and uh it was pretty chaotic
you know living with my mom she had
already met another guy so she was on
her second husband and uh that was
really chaotic what was your dad going
through that he committed suicide
um he was having some relationship
conflicts with a girlfriend of his and
doing a lot of cocaine and
um
and she just couldn't handle it you know
definitely some mental health issues
there to go that far as to kill yourself
right
so how would you describe your childhood
in general
um pretty sad I was really depressed a
lot
um we moved like every year really
transient lifestyle you know it's always
a different School a different apartment
so
um I didn't really have that core group
of friends growing up like a lot of kids
do and
um I definitely had my own issues
you know growing up in that household I
was very angry
and uh I displayed a lot of problematic
behaviors in school got in a lot of
fights and
stuff like that which is unfortunate
because I'm really smart
but yeah school was definitely a problem
for me you finished high school I didn't
I got a GED and I enlisted in the Coast
Guard and I got an honorable discharge
from there
and I started going to uh prison soon
after I got out of the Coast Guard
um
that's very institutionalized at that
point I grew up my mom didn't really
know how to parent so when she didn't
know what to do she relied on juvenile
hall or um
or uh hospitals to take care of me
so I went from doing that to joining the
military and then getting out I started
going to jail
I uh I came out here actually to Surf I
uh I I always lived near the beach and
um I don't know if you've heard of it
but there's a movie called The Endless
Summer and I actually went surfing with
those guys and I told them how
inspirational they were and they said
well put your money where your mouth is
you know you go travel so I came out
here in hopes of uh you know just living
that lifestyle and I got caught up in
drugs instead
and uh the last time I went to prison
was actually um
pretty crazy I went for uh stealing some
coffee out of a Gelson's in Reseda and I
ended up stabbing someone and fighting a
life sentence
and that was a real eye-opener for me I
um
I dropped out of the gang I was in about
a year after that happened and I got
clean and sober and I got my first
college degree in prison I got an
associate in arts and alcohol and drug
studies
and when I got out I got a job as a
chemical dependency technician and um
I haven't been back since
you know
um
it was pretty rewarding working in the
recovery industry
I liked it a lot
and I was it was really exciting I got
my uh full full-on credential to be a
counselor and a counselor supervisor and
a pretty colorful few years working
different jobs and in rehabs and in
different facilities
and then um I suffered a pretty
traumatic spinal injury bodybuilding and
um
I had to give back seven years clean and
sober because I was on all the
painkillers to help me manage the
chronic pain that that went along with
um my injury
and it's just been a downward spiral
since so you got clean yeah seven years
for seven years yeah and then you had to
clean I got a master's degree I married
a doctor my life was amazing and then
uh this injuries just
I haven't I haven't gotten back up from
it you hurt your back yeah I hurt my
back painkillers yeah and they just you
know they they uh they turned me into
someone I I'm not you know I I've made
some really bad decisions I um
was it awful husband
um
I caught a criminal case you know
punching someone in the face you know
just things I wouldn't do clean and
sober I mean so you from from what I
hear from your story so far you're
you're two people you're incredibly
intelligent and articulate and the
biggest idiot and then you do this
terribly self-destructive yes yeah
that's a fair statement
so is that because of the drug use that
you get like that yeah I just
I don't know what to say I just I do
things you know when I'm loaded that
I've never even think of doing when I
when I'm not
um when I'm clean and sober I help
people I'm I'm kind generous you know um
loving
um and when I'm not I uh
I'm pretty vicious I'll do anything I
have to do to keep that high going
but it's been your drug
um
it's it was heroin growing up I started
doing heroin when I was 14.
um my dad's uh best friend used to take
me on heroin runs
um and since I was a kid I would hold
the drugs
because there wouldn't be really any
consequences for me if I were to get
caught
and um yeah I
I grew up doing opiates and um
giving back the seven years there wasn't
this fentanyl stuff around last time I
was using now it's kind of taken over
and um
it's so much harder to get off of I've
been to two rehabs in the last month and
I I can't handle the withdrawals they're
just awful
harder to quit than heroin oh so much
harder
not just physically but emotionally too
it's like as soon as I start to get
straight I just have this crippling
depression come over me
um
and and back to the things I wouldn't do
like um
clean and sober David would definitely
choose his family over drugs you know
but uh I I can't kick this stuff
that's why I'm not here you know uh
my family won't talk to me friends don't
talk to me you know it's it looks like
I'm choosing the jokes over them but
it's just
um
I don't know what to say I can't uh I
can't kick
stuff where do you stay now
um
wherever I end up uh crashing I uh
I'm doing a lot of meth too to stay
awake so that I don't fall victims of
robberies and you know stealing and
stuff like that so I'm usually up for a
few days and then I'll finally crash out
like I try to make it towards West LA or
the beach
safer out there
than not in town otherwise it's an
endless cycle of falling asleep and
getting robbed and falling asleep yeah
yeah
how do you support yourself crime
I'm doing a lot of stealing a lot of
property crime
um
yeah taking stuff from stores going uh
downtown to fences you take it and um
take that money and Buy Dope
yeah shame of an education yeah no
kidding how does it affect you
emotionally to be living this life I'm
so ashamed of myself
yeah if I didn't if I didn't need a
payout I would definitely not be telling
anyone this
yes it's a child
I had a uh a child from a previous
relationship who um
who died
um
a few months before I broke my back oh
wow
sorry
just it's hard to deal with you know
I started to get clean and
and this stuff weighs real heavy on me
do you have hope of ever getting off of
Fentanyl
yeah I uh I have an appointment Tuesday
I'm gonna try detox again
at a place called The Red Gate in uh
Long Beach
have you tried Suboxone
I uh I did um a suboxone maintenance
program as part of my pain management
for my back and
I don't want to be on anything you know
I uh
yeah I want my life and my family back
so uh
I'm gonna keep trying it
you still talk with your wife
no
no
um
everyone's pretty much done with me
until I get clean
understandably so yeah
do you have friends
um
yeah I do
I have a
uh you know I'm running around doing
this and living this lifestyle and I
know it hurts everyone so I kind of just
um
isolated myself I don't really uh Reach
Out
it's the shame probably yeah
would you describe yourself as
self-destructive oh yeah yeah especially
on drugs yeah
I've been trying to take myself out for
a couple months you know I see all these
people turn blue taking a hit of this
Fentanyl and I'm like
sit there and smoke a gram and not even
fall asleep
definitely jealous
yeah
you'd like to
oh yeah I'd rather die than live this
way this is terrible
awful existence it's full of violence
and
self-degregation and
yeah
what are you afraid of
more of this
yeah
just hurting my family more making them
go through
watching me uh do this over and over you
know it's my biggest fear
if you had your life you live all over
again what would you have done
differently
I would never ever take that first drug
yeah if I could go back I'd
and what do they teach kids uh just say
no and just say no
sounds great on paper right yeah
you've been on the streets for how long
uh about three months
um
like I said I I caught a criminal case
and
um
I was on probation and
I haven't been in trouble since 2013 and
as soon as I signed for probation it was
within weeks I I violated I so I just
walked away from
my life
I wasn't working in the in the
Humanities field I was actually doing
title Contracting
um which is a lot more lucrative than
social work and um you know I violated
probation so I pretty much walked away
from everything I was living in a luxury
condo out in Palm Springs and
you know I had my own this driving
business employees contracts that were
yet to be completed and I walked away
and
uh disappeared for a couple months I
didn't reach out to anyone friends or
family
for about two months and they put a
missing person's report out on me and
um
I just um
I couldn't take missing my life
so I
I reached out and
let everyone know where I was and what I
was doing I'd actually gone down to
Mexico
and I planned on flying from Mexico to
France where they don't extradite and
drugs got in the way again I was getting
high and I fell asleep and my foot came
off the break and I hit the car in front
of me and when the
Mexicans police arrived and did a search
they found uh
like 15 dime bags and 1500 bucks and my
gun
and I said I was a dealer so instead of
just taking the 100 payoff like usual
they took everything including my car
and down in Mexico if you don't have the
title you can't get your car out so
I didn't want to be stuck down in Mexico
strung out so I figured LA's the
place to be
speaking with you you seem so rational
and intelligent
but you come from
both your mom and dad who seem to have
mental issues
well I mean my dad yeah you think you've
inherited some of that yeah for sure
um
I deal with a lot of suicidal ideations
a lot of depression
has he been on psych medications I have
yeah
um
I don't really think it helps
um I'm not on it now I don't see the
point in taking the stuff if I'm you
know smoking a grandma fetty every day
probably wouldn't work anyways
yeah it's interesting how some people
can
their bodies can tolerate
fentanyl more than others yeah yeah I
smoke enough to kill a horse daily
who's your favorite memory
ah
I remember one day my mom
um
picked me up from school early and uh
took me to the movies
we saw the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
that was a good one
sweet
who are you closer to Mom or Dad
well you know definitely my mom you know
my dad did what he did when I was five
so oh well we never developed that
relationship
how did your dad kill himself
he uh
he shot himself
yeah
he
he shot himself with an assault rifle in
his girlfriend's driveway
so I you had to answer your question I
definitely inherited that I think about
doing stuff like that a lot
you know
David what'd you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
things
people are going to come and go learn
how to stand on your own too
all right David thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah thank you I wish
you the best of luck from here thank you
thanks